[Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  and it feels like  the beginning of me reclaiming my life i  can put this behind me completely now he  was a skilled sexual predator who preyed  on his victims and after grooming them  he inflicted significant emotional and  sometimes physical harm  on them which in some cases will  continue to hurt them for the rest of  their lives  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  there wasn't a day in my life  up until this moment that i actually  believed that the judicial system would  come through for black and brown girls  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you